today's topic Azra Miller appears to
choke a woman in a video who's as
vanilla use a actor who played the flesh
oh yeah I thought so apparently this was
a fan who really liked his stuff and
then it was getting very close to him
and then put his hands on him and he was
showing his scars from battles and then
she said well I can fight you took her
off the fighter that's what happened
okay what do you think about it I really
don't care about but I do think is
interesting is that mainstream media has
picked this up in huge numbers and
they're still quiet about amber that's
what we're going but you know what she's
about maybe to be canceled it's fired
from a job from Aquaman still not yet
confirmed even though there's evidence
of her admitting to it she might do a
little physically putting her hands on
deck doing all kinds of stuff apparently
chopping off his finger right still
nothing all these news articles they're
picking up this 7 second video and
making a big deal about it but you got
deposition after deposition of this
woman lying between caught out lying
admitting to hitting and you guys still
do nothing this is the whole thing that
makes me laugh about this I gotta listen
to these people grandstanding about how
bad Ezra Miller is about this and that
fine I'm like yo you've got one right
there but because it was between her
legs she get a pass we call it a piss
right man pants when you got a poon boom
and you get a pass it's pretty much hip
I just remember seeing the headlines and
I was like Oh kiss y'all pick this one
up but y'all still ain't talked about
heard ain't you heard no cuz then talk
about it your public disrespect should
be equal to your public apology you did
all that salt but you're not gonna say
nothing about that that's why it's wrong
we chose one side so now it's not the
right story oops we're not gonna say
anything cuz I want a girl yeah that's
you and it wasn't you and then she finds
out that she was wrong
he's waiting for an apology like
oh wow and they just leave that Valley
what this is it's not an apology it's
just awkward
all of these her two activists they're
so fake
they're so fake these I is well active
they're so fake look at Alyssa Milano
who had all these tweets about men in
power need to be held accountable if you
do something you should have to pay it's
not because you're powerful that you
should and then Joe Biden comes along
and she was like I endorsed Joe Biden
and everyone calls around said well this
is different
Joe Biden okay good
there have been against Joe about us
right and people were saying how do we
do that
I have not publicly said anything about
this if you remember it kind of took me
a long time to publicly say anything
about about Harvey as well because I
believe that even though we should
believe women and that is an important
thing and what that statement really
means is like you know for so long
the the go-to has been not to believe
them so really we have to sort of
societally change that mindset to
believing women but that does not mean
at the expense of not you know giving
men their due process here's what I'm
coming to realize social justice
warriors their movement is and it's
dunzo it's been deleted it's not
credible every time things hit the fan
all of a sudden their values are gone
social justice warriors are not made for
war they're not they're gonna be able to
shoot when it doesn't matter that much
now when people fight back crickets
crickets there's nothing you don't get
to pick and choose when it benefits you
that is not the definition of equality
at all I checked I checked you checked
that's not what it is the Equality they
claim not their B pick and choose what
they want so yeah I want to talk about
Trump this whole time but the moment
that dimension Joe gets a call out all
of a sudden you guys want to support
endorse him so is it about your values
or is about hating the orange man do you
want equality or you want man Andy Capp
we're asking the questions we're asking
the questions because that's what it
looks like when you claim that you want
equality going but only when equality
serves you that is not equality it's not
is it
it's not social justice warriors are not
made for war that's it you listen
trusted mainstream media has been an
all-time low for the last couple of
years
what and it's gonna keep sinking because
they're arrogant and we see through them
and it's garbage yeah when the
propaganda is just not even hidden
anymore
ruff when the when that's open play when
da agenda is not even hidden anymore
it's just right there you see it is
their trash but anyways that's it for
today's we don't test what you guys
think do you guys agree with our
sentiment do you disagree tell us why No
[Music]
learn it did you want to fight what do
you think any thoughts no I don't have
any thoughts I mean I don't really care
to me that is a non-issue doesn't really
mean anything it's a report that
happened and said that yo you know what
she said this he said that whatever
whatever it is and then this with this
little clip I can't I don't know what
the moon with her at the end of the day
I was not there and basing myself on
this little clip I can't just go out and
be like yeah this is what happened and
if it's wrong or this is good I can't
really do it because there's not enough
for me to say anything there's a core
system if she wants to sue she'll sue
and there's gonna be hush money that's
been pretty much it and in two weeks
we're not gonna hear about it my name is
Harper rose no Canadians know but I have
made out with some the last guy that I
dated was unlike any other guy I've ever
dated before because I'm about five
seven and this guy was really I picked
it to cocaine so this why are you doing
this
is that what's going on you're doing it
really you're doing your bits why okay
you already sex with a comedian move on
sorry
there's something very disingenuous when
you there's something so weird when you
think you're just you know what you're
just talking to a comic backstage or
whatever you hanging out and and then
there's a part of the conversation where
someone feels off and you think they
just try to joke on you you try to joke
on yeah well call it yeah if you wanna
try joke on someone tell them tell them
yeah it's fine right in the conversation
like that but you just said yo it's okay
like why do you think why do you dislike
that so much when people try out so
cheesy [ __ ] made me switch languages
I have no idea why why hmm
I don't like that cuz here's a theme
it's like sometimes we're on stage and
we're doing her act okay
but while we're off stages like I we're
just having interaction we're having a
conversation and you're gonna violate
that by trying your act on me without
letting me know
does that make sense you're just being
disingenuous yeah it feels like this is
you know it's disingenuous it's just
night you're not on stage bro it's like
this
oh [ __ ] with us yeah yeah yeah no it's
good I see your act and that's fine in
that context is good but when you try to
act on me to see if it works or to try
to garner some reaction I'm like bro you
do that with the audience you'll have to
do that with me this is weird
do you know I'm saying I don't even know
working I never try my jokes on people
like that I do it on stage and that's
why I test it out outside that it seems
weird to you okay now you're gonna treat
me like I'm your audience that's weird
to me do you think what I'm saying
that's how I know I've always hated
welcome to the Harper oh so I know I've
personally always hated it what would it
be akin to can you imagine if you're
just in the middle of a conversation
with somebody and they just start
singing for you a song that they wrote
or okay I got it
you know when you're in a car with a
friend who's a musician and like y'all
wanna play something for you and like
yeah okay you're on DJ and they start
playing their own music yeah and the
card is their own music playing no no
you're a passenger but like I'll DJ for
this right and then they start playing
their own music just throwing it in
there
he's just like bro come on if you want
me to yeah thank you
there's something weird about that as I
go you'll have to test it out like
that's weird to me it feels like
self-promotion almost